[Music]
we made this video selfishly for me
because i was so obsessed with reliving
my childhood my grandmother lived pretty
close to me growing up and every year
she would have each of her grandkids
over to do fun holiday themed activities
it's one of those things where as a kid
you don't realize how special that is
but it's been super nostalgic
[Music]
so my aunt ginger went through all of my
grandma's old christmas stuff took her a
few weeks she finally dug it up and she
sent me a photo of it honestly i kind of
gasped when i saw the recipe because it
had handwritten notes all over it some
of it were highlighted it was discolored
it was so old my grandmother had written
it on her old typewriter like pulled on
my heartstrings when i first saw it it
was
it was really cool because especially
like when i was a kid i never saw the
recipe because she would always make it
so being able to kind of look back and
see this was
i don't know it was really special it's
a reminder that all recipes are living
and this is at least how i do it like i
always take notes myself
we use kosher salt here at tasty it's
not going to sift the way that all the
other ingredients are so i just put it
in separately
[Music]
so much can change in a recipe when
different people do it my grandma
recommended using non-stick spray on the
dutch oven that you're using so even if
you're using like a non-stick surface it
still helps it release a little bit
better so this is actually called a
melting method cookie we're making it in
a pot which is not typical of a lot of
cookies but because this has so much
liquid in this recipe it's a perfect
melting melted oh my gosh it's a perfect
melting method cookie
so what we're really trying to do is
dissolve the sugar and all about liquid
and bring this to a boil really quickly
just to make sure that all of the sugar
is melted
a cup at a time we're going to
incorporate the dry ingredients into the
wet you have to be super precise about
this it gets very hard to stir once you
incorporate more of the flour she says
use four cups and then use the remaining
cup when you're kind of kneading the
dough together
it smells so good what do they say that
smell is closest tied to memory my
grandma always said we don't eat this
gingerbread maybe that was just so that
we wouldn't eat it so that we could use
it for the house we tried it and it's
pretty good
thanks for your help
it's heavy there's a lot in there
you want to work this when it's pretty
warm it's going to settle a little bit
and be kind of a loose dough but it
shouldn't be super super sticky a lot of
her notes were like basically saying
don't use all the flour um so i was
trying to be aware of that as i was
kneading this together it's funny i wish
i could ask her these questions but i
can't so she was very precise in saying
that you needed to divide this dough
into three pieces and use the three
different pieces to cut out the
different shapes i'm gonna put these two
pieces back in that warm dutch oven
again you wanna work this when it's
pretty warm so as with anything that
you're rolling out you wanna be aware
that you're starting with the shape you
wanna end with and i'm gonna do that
thing with my rolling pin where i kind
of press the dough before i start
rolling always rotating the dough about
a quarter turn every now and then just
to make sure that the dough is not
sticking
[Music]
between like a quarter and a third of an
inch is probably a good thickness for
this the thing about making a house is
you do want to be careful that you're
cutting straight lines while a ruler is
not totally necessary
i would recommend it wait till you guys
see this we have templates for you to
use you can print them out and use them
for your own house at home this is a top
tip that my grandma left in the recipe
so cut out the windows and stuff but
leave them in place don't take them out
and then just recut them when the pieces
come out of the oven and that will
ensure that the windows and the doors
stay intact just to make sure you have
like super crisp edges
i mean definitely use your discretion
here and it comes out pretty easily you
don't want to use a knife again it's not
too difficult you just cut it and pry it
out
so here you can see on the left is where
we left the pieces in and cut them
afterwards and on the right we took them
out before baking it's kind of a cute
look but wasn't the look that we were
going for you definitely want to let
these bad boys cool before you do
anything with them i would even make
these a day ahead of time if you know
that you're gonna be making these and we
figured we'd thrown in a bonus recipe
for you guys this year it's a softer
gingerbread since you won't be eating
the house this is like a little bit more
palatable a little bit softer you know
and more edible
it's honestly like a really similar
recipe butter makes it better so we're
gonna use butter in this one for like a
little bit of a softer effect and a
little bit of better flavor
we're going to add our brown sugar to
this and completely dissolve it it gets
pretty thick with this one it's really
like nice and shiny so once the sugar is
totally melted and you can't really feel
any more granules go ahead and turn off
the heat i'm going to add a little bit
of lemon zest and then we're going to
mix in one egg and breathe the egg
before just to make sure that it
incorporates really evenly into that
mixture same deal we're going to
gradually add our dry to our wet and mix
it all in until it's a good homogeneous
dough that's going to prevent lumps and
just make it a little bit easier to
hydrate that flower more quickly then
hopefully you have a friend around to
help you get this out of this dutch oven
and go ahead and kind of smush this
together so it's one nice disc and
you're gonna let this chill in the
fridge for about two hours or overnight
would be great so now that our dough is
completely chilled roll it out to about
a quarter of an inch thickness
and then just again making sure that the
bottom is not sticking to the board so
get your hands under there make sure
you're using enough flour that's not
sticking
i don't need anything to be like a
perfect shape here again always making
sure that it's not sticking to the board
now you can start with the cookie
cutters i like to put a little bit of
flour on the side of the board whenever
i'm using cookie cutters because you
want to flour the cutter a little bit so
that it doesn't stick or take any of the
dough back with you knock off any excess
and then go ahead and make little cuts
in the dough press down evenly a little
bit of a shimmy a little bit of a shake
to make sure that you're really getting
like a good cut and that you're
separating the shape from the rest of
the dough around it
if you like a much softer gingerbread
definitely take these out when they're
just set but if you like to have more of
that snap bake them a little bit longer
and then once they're cool enough to
handle you can eat them as is you can
decorate them if you want add more candy
to these not my gumdrop buttons name the
movie just kidding
this is a pretty classic royal icing
though she uses egg whites we use
pasteurized egg whites with this just in
case anyone is eating it if you don't
want to use egg whites you could also
use meringue powder a little bit of
cream of tartar so the egg whites are
going to not only strengthen the
frosting but also make it harden so this
frosting will be super super hard when
it dries this is like structuralizing i
mean this stuff is basically a spackle
i'm pretty sure you could tile your
bathroom with this stuff i would keep it
on the thicker side for building but
then for decorating you can thin it out
a little bit it'd be much easier to work
with so because it's tasty we just can't
help ourselves take it to the next level
the sides of the walls can expand so a
really cool trick is to use a little
micro grater and go along the side in a
straight line and that will help sand
off the sides as my grandma always said
frosting can fix everything so if
there's any little cracks or
imperfections just put some frosting on
it if you've seen an old video called
aquarium cookies we did this really cool
thing where you can put hard candies in
the middle of a cookie and then bake it
it gives you kind of like a colored
glass window effect and we wanted this
house to be really colorful and fun so
we decided to do it with all of our
windows and doors so the hard candies
might not spread all the way but you can
use a little toothpick or a skewer if
you have one and just really gently push
the extra sugar out to the edges if
you're gonna do the glass effect make
sure that it is very cool so don't touch
it again until the candy is completely
reset if you've ever made a gingerbread
house before the roof can be the roof
the roof the roof can slide down because
of the weight of it so she is ingenious
and she would frost a heavy grocery bag
to the underside of the roof and then
have it dry with two bowls underneath it
so if you want to you can put two little
bowls under each side of the roof so
that it dries in the shape that it's
gonna eventually be in and make sure
that it's super super dry before you
keep building it'll be pretty much rock
hard it doesn't take that long maybe
like 30 minutes or so
we just use cake board here but you can
use whatever you have there's something
sturdy enough that'll hold the weight of
the gingerbread house this is good to do
while your roof is drying because you
also want the walls to be set before you
put the roof on put your pieces up to it
to see where you should be piping that
frosting yeah a nice snowy surface
you want to get the sides set and then
you want to make sure that you're
putting frosting up the side when in
doubt put frosting on the inside when
you can and that's going to really help
give structure to the house so i'm going
to hold these pieces here and then pipe
on the inside
so there will be a bit of extra frosting
on the outside so you can use your
finger or a knife if you want to clean
that up or you can just leave it there
it's pretty classic gingerbread to have
a bunch of frosting coming out the seams
as well and you want it to be set so
that doesn't move right and then go
ahead and put a whole bunch of frosting
all over the top
and lay on the roof
so as you can see the paper bag trick
worked thanks grandma k so now with all
the remaining frosting that we have
we're going to thin it out a little bit
and make it a little bit easier to work
with more flowy if you will so just put
that back into a bowl and add a little
bit of water
it's time to have fun honestly like
these are an artistic expression so you
can go like really extra and make it
really fun and just throw a bunch of
candy on honestly i think a few years
what i just did was put all of my
favorite candy all over the house so
that throughout the month i could take
the icing off the house whatever your
motive is be real be you just do
whatever you want to do
first of all gingerbread houses are a
good activity because it's just an
excuse to eat candy
[Music]
it's a great activity to do with people
when it's really cold outside you kind
of want to like bundle up you know
cuffing season stuff
[Music]
we did it as a tasty family this year
and it was like really fun activity i
think everyone really enjoyed it
keeps everyone excited and kind of
brings out the child like wonder of the
holidays i don't know i really just fell
in love with this process again so much
you got to do this guys i can't say it
enough i hope you guys enjoy it as much
as we did
[Music]
now my gumdrop buttons
you sound just like it onions have
layers ogres have layers you didn't we
both have layers
oh you both have layers fine you cannot
i cannot have my life without you like i
the fact that you're just like perfectly
executed that i can't